hey we're in San Francisco David Josh
and myself and we are here for an epic
trip actually we're going from San
Francisco to Seattle we've got seven
stories to shoot couple turning points
five millionaires and it's going to be
amazing
we wanted to kind of bring you along for
the ride see some of the behind the
scenes stuff meet the folks that we that
we get to talk to when we travel yeah
check it out
[Music]
we are at new year Woods National
Monument and the trees here are amazing
they're ginormous this is my first time
in the redwood forest and it's
phenomenal
[Music]
we just had breakfast at the perfect
pour in Pacifica and we are headed to
we're headed to Justin and Sarah doesn't
Sierra's house
it's lovely out and we're going to do
this now so here we go
[Music]
that's done with our first shoe of the
week with Justin and Sarah and it was
fantastic
possibly the most scenic shoot we've
done absolutely their success story
because it sacrificed a lot they still
live in a place where the cost of living
is really high but they live life on
their own terms there are young cuz
they're not even in they're 30 and
already doing exactly what they want to
do so we're inspired by
there is something really life-giving
about meeting these folks and hearing
their stories just breaking time with
them
I don't know it's harder to describe
exactly but it's very inspiring I love
it
[Music]
[Music]
so this is what our room looks like
every night we're going to bed and we've
been charging it's Tuesday morning and
we are headed to Modesto California to
shoot Turning Point with Ross we had a
full day yesterday and I detect no
different today
[Music]
all right it's Wednesday morning we are
on our way to Allen in the Loomis
California which is a little north east
of Sacramento this is a day that would
begin our trek north after Allen we're
going to be headed to Medford Oregon and
then from Medford would have bands from
Bend we go to Eugene but we're staying
south of Portland and then from there we
head up to Seattle and we have Olympia
it's got crazy
[Music]
we are headed to Medford Oregon we have
about a five hour drive ahead of us we
just met with Alan he is our first
millionaire that were shooting in this
week long road trip I really liked Alan
and Pam they were lovely lovely people
we have the Alison Lohman school Stadium
and we it runs Bluetooth and the app is
failing on both of our phones so now
we've got to do all of our shots with a
drone which is not a bad thing
[Music]
[Applause]
so it's Thursday morning and we are
headed to meet Larry Indy they are our
second millionaire shoot of the week we
met with Larry and in the last night
Josh and I did they wanted to meet up
and converse and get the nervousness out
of the way we're looking forward to
chatting with them and hearing their
story more sharing it with you the
viewer
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we are in Oregon listening
to the December there from Oregon so
looking fitted which left with Larry and
B they were fantastic and man Larry made
a delectable thing would you stay with
delectable David yeah I think it was
delectable they moved to Oregon from
California because they wanted to live
in this natural environment with the
Rogue River behind them so they did that
they took care of their money for many
many years and now they can do it they
have a redwood tree in their backyard
200 year old redwoods fantastic Hill is
amazing we are on our way to Bend Oregon
to be with Jim and on our way we're
going to stop in Union Creek and have
lunch at Becky's Catherine cafe here and
or again we're going to really explore
downtown chemicals come on come on
you
[Music]
it is Friday Blaine and we are in Sun
River just south the band in here going
to be meeting me Jim and Mary Jim is a
really interesting guy he worked for
Intel and some of the stuff he was
telling us was kind of blowing our minds
a little bit maybe just I'm sleeping but
we're going to Portland later today well
that's
[Music]
longer with Jim and Mary were about to
chat with them and get their story and
yeah you guys ready already awesome
let's go do it
[Music]
it's Saturday we are on our way that our
second to the last shoe it's key he's
our fourth Niner we're heading down to
Eugene's but the ninth Portland last
night we got a little goodie don't act
aloof we're on the homestretch of our
trip here we're down to the end here and
when it finishes Dona
this has been the most ambitious work
trip that I've ever been a part of and
it's an extremely satisfying I'm tired
I'm spent
by my heart is full of joy and I'm sure
today's video shoot tomorrow than the
next day two issues and those that meant
we've got like seven more November I'm
done
[Music]
you
you're headed to Seattle now just finish
up with Pete ah stop
on the trip
we're at Mon Amour fall and just outside
of Portland Oregon
you see the nest is alive and well
[Music]
[Music]
we are actually in Mike's marketplace
here we're going to check out the public
market and breakfast okay
so we've made it to our last unit of the
week this is number seven of seven and
it's with a Paul and Elaine and they
have a beautiful property here on this
wonderful lake and in the distance is
Mount Rainier and we're ready to get
some sentences we are right
and
the
you
[Music]